[موسيقى]
أجنبية
هذه
[موسيقى]
تمكنت طالبان الآن من الوصول إلى أكثر من 85
مليار دولار من
المعدات العسكرية الأمريكية
التي تشمل 75000 مركبة
وأكثر من 200 طائرة وطائرة هليكوبتر وأكثر من
600000 سلاح صغير و  الأسلحة الخفيفة
تمتلك طالبان الآن عددًا من
طائرات الهليكوبتر من طراز بلاك هوك أكثر من 85 دولة
في العالم
[موسيقى]
ولكن ليس لديهم أسلحة فحسب ،
بل لديهم أيضًا نظارات الرؤية الليلية
والدروع الواقية للبدن والمستلزمات الطبية وهي أن
طالبان لديها الآن أجهزة بيومترية
والتي  احصل على بصمات بصمات
مسح العين ومعلومات السيرة
الذاتية للأفغان
الذين ساعدونا
على مدار العشرين عامًا الماضية ،
هل هذه الإدارة لا تزال ليس لديها
خطة
لإعادة هذه المعدات العسكرية أو هذه
الإمدادات
بدلاً من ذلك سقطت كلها في
أيدي طالبان
[موسيقى]